welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker on this
episode I talk with Ander Sandberg from
the future of humanity Institute at
Oxford University
we discuss various philosophical
paradoxes surrounding the value of the
long-term future
for example our values change over time
and so should we evaluate the value of
the future based on our current values
or based on the values we will hold in
the future
we also end the episode with a lightning
round in which I asked Anders his
opinions about mind uploading aliens and
what the most plausible moral theory is
here is Ander Sandberg
great Anders thank you for coming on the
podcast
well thank you for having me here
all right so there is this uh metaphor
of humanity as an immature teenager how
much do you agree with this is this an
accurate metaphor
like any metaphor it's not perfectly
accurate teenagers or in some sense in a
particular developmental program so some
of the biological changes in teenagers
make sense for an individual but doesn't
apply to a civilization yet I think
there is a lot of aptness to it too it's
both an immaturity we don't have good
ways of controlling our actions as a
civilization we don't really know what
we're doing we're also overconfident
about it and we have a fairly large
amount of power that can allow us to
hurt ourselves or other things of value
in the world
I think one one thing that the metaphor
is trying to convey is this uh picture
of us becoming smart before we become
wise so we are we are smart enough to
invent nuclear weapons but not wise
enough to know how to control them
yeah I think wisdom is very much being
able to set your goals well and in some
sense smarts can allow you to be wise
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you have applied your smartness on that
domain and indeed we are still
struggling with figuring out what's
truly uh worth doing and even when we
know what's worth doing we might not
necessarily have a self-control so to
say as a society or a species to
actually Implement that rather well the
aftermath of kovid for example
demonstrates that we actually have a
pretty good list of things that should
be done to prevent new pandemics and so
far most governments have not been
working their way through that list to
actually Safeguard against it one way in
which the analogy might break down is
this fact that a teenager is perhaps 20
through his or her life but Humanity
could potentially be only one percent or
less through through our existence on
the other hand we could also potentially
be very close to the end if we do not
accurately control
various existential risks so
what what is it that we're trying to
convey with this with this metaphor is
it simply that that we should we should
become wise or we should do more to not
destroy ourselves as a species
I think that's one aspect of it I think
quite a lot of a metaphor is about
reaching maturity of some kind but
people are not just becoming mature by
being wiser sometimes it's by getting
more skills or settling in in a
comfortable role in their society or
doing sort of things there is more to
Growing Up than just becoming wise
indeed most of us don't accumulate much
wisdom even when we're middle-aged
I want to talk about values in the
future and which values will be will be
followed and and which values perhaps
should be followed when we when we talk
about there being a lot at stake if
Humanity goes extinct we're assuming
some kind of value for example we are
assuming that Humanity itself is is
valuable the existence of humanity is
good which almost everyone agrees with
but definitely there are some people who
disagree and so
you have an interesting discussion in
your book uh Grand Futures about value
drift which is the the distinction
between our values now if we can talk
accurately about the values of humanity
and then the values that Humanities
descendants will have say in a thousand
years because you explain this concept
of value drift
so right now we have a set of things
with value some of them are simple
things like your happiness and absence
of pain some of them are artistic and
spiritual goals some of them are ethical
principles like autonomy and the
equality
so we generally would say a world with a
lot of these valuable things in it would
be a good world of course some of them
are also coming into conflict with each
other so resolving these conflicts are
an ongoing big project
but there is this disturbing thought but
we also have differences in our values
from the past so today in the sexism and
homophobia racism they are not seen as
acceptable indeed very seen as entirely
immoral positions to have now in the
past there would have been a lot of
people even in our own culture but it
would have said oh that's neutral or
even in the case of homophobia no no
that is what God wants us to do it's a
positive value you are the bad guys
because you actually accept the case oh
no that's a horrible decline of morality
and then we can have an inter-temporal
argument here about who was right
meanwhile the Romans are known as saying
oh compassion that's for little old
ladies clemences with proper virtue here
for a real man uh why are you going on
about that you have really declined you
don't even talk about honor very much
so you could argue of course that we
have a moral development but actually we
have learned important moral truths
actually today we are better at morality
than the Romans we have actually figured
things out the relativists at this point
might beg to differ but generally even
the relativists might say that yeah
pleasure is better than pain and that's
something even a distant ancestors among
Fishers would agree with if they could
do philosophy now the problem here is in
the future we are going to change
Natural Evolution is going to change us
a bit randomly but more powerfully it's
pretty likely that we are going to
modify ourselves our culture is going to
change way more than between us and the
Romans and we're also likely to want to
modify our bodies to fix problems like
aging and maybe enhance ourselves
and that means that in the long run
we're probably going to become something
vastly different and probably at a
faster Pace than in the past
so that means that we might discover new
values and that might sound good if
you're an optimist about moral
development okay the post you must of
the future have discovered this value X
that they say is way better than
equality and justice and all but we're
going on they still acknowledge the
equality and just as good values but X
is actually super important so they're
going to work hard on making sure
there's a lot of X in the world that
might still be all right because there
is a bit of equality and justice in that
world but it might also be that we can't
imagine what that value is like at all
because we merely have 1.4 liters of
bread we don't have any quantum
computers connected to our brains and
that's unfortunate what you need to have
in order to understand these values and
if you're slightly less optimistic about
moral advancement you might say actually
culture is drifting randomly and it is
very different world where we're living
there in the service and space habitats
and doing very Quantum thinking
their culture is utterly alien to us so
it encompasses values we can't fathom
and don't care about so actually the
total amount of value in that culture
might be very small the occasionally is
a bit of glimmer of equality or a bit of
happiness but they're mostly aiming at
getting value x y and said that we don't
have any clue about and some very
disturbing weird things that we might
call Alf bath and gimmel but it's even
weirder and they might conversely also
be a bit concerned but maybe the post
post humans of a very far future are
going to not care too much about the X Y
and said
so this leads to some problems for us
thinking about long-term instrument how
good the long-term future could be
there is there's a Temptation here to
say that well in the past we were simply
wrong uh about our attitudes towards
sexism racism slavery you name it there
are so many horrors of the past now we
know better
um and and so the the past people were
simply wrong what what this should make
us think about is how we could be wrong
in this step in a similar sense
here one might worry that
you know it's we cannot give up on all
of our values in some sense I think at
least it makes sense to be stubborn
about some of them otherwise we could we
could be uh you could call it black
males by our thinking about future
people so so that they uh dictate what
we should believe
um do you see any value in being
stubborn about uh our current values
well I think it if we're careful about
our thinking about the current values
that is the best knowledge we have at
this moment in time and we might know
that there is better knowledge to be had
but we can't really try to base things
on our inklings about that knowledge if
we have good reasons to believe
something about that knowledge we should
just incorporate it right now in our
values for example uh I'm slowly
drifting to where it's becoming a proper
vegetarian I should just cut to the
chase because it's pretty obvious that
that's where my values and the
practicalities are going actually I
should just cut out meat in this case it
might not be a seriously bad thing but
still it's slightly bad and I should
probably just try to be a bit more
rational about it now in practice we
have this problem but we know that there
might be ongoing moral disasters just
like slavery was largely ignored as a
moral disaster certainly there's people
recognizing that there is something icky
going on here you can find inside that
throughout history that people do
recognize but actually the slaves are
like us and we're treating them badly
and I could even have been in that
slave's place but most of us glimmering
so maybe this is bad never really got
anywhere until abolitionist really
started developing and similarly we
might be of course doing the same thing
there are a few plausible candidates
like maybe factory farming is going to
be just regarded by the future as
absolutely horrendous and how could they
do that well they had all the facts yet
why did it take so long but I bet that
the really big moral resources going on
right now is something that nobody is
thinking seriously about at all and in
many ways it's going to be interesting
to see if we get to know what it is but
it's probably going to be making us
cringe but oh yes why didn't we see that
now the problem here is of course
that set of future values assuming
they're much better that might give us a
reason to try to research them intensely
it's a bit like unique bostrom's
argument for exploring the space of
post-human the states because there is
an ongoing discussion among critics of
transhume management transumers why
should you want to become something
other than human isn't the point of
being an excellent human to be an
excellent human you don't really want to
exit Being Human and Nick's argument is
that will burn states of being among
humans that are really good that we
should justly strive for very very
excellent and there is a vastly largest
base of possible post-human States and
by induction we should guess that we're
at least as good values out there as the
best ones we can get and there might
very well be even more valuable States
and we should want to pursue them
because we want to pursue value
now things are of course tricky because
you might say yeah but is that human
value or value as seen by some
independent Observer from kind of
subspecies Alternatives uh value that's
not linked to any individual Observer
but kind of from a neutral Universal
perspective so depending on your theory
about value and who it's valuable to you
might end up with very different answers
and the same thing goes with this
inter-temporal comparison of values the
post-humans might be very satisfied but
they have great values and they made
more progress but that doesn't mean that
we should try to embrace random
post-humor values and how bad is it we
should Instead try to examine the find
Pathways that lead to these values and
that is also where I think we get to one
of the non-trivial predictions but there
might be valid and invalid paths to high
value so it could be for example that by
totally rearranging my brain into a
completely different being a good
experience really great values except I
could honestly say it's not me anymore
the past and there's a future Anders
have no connection except that it was
the same atoms there is no real identity
here there is no link at all it's almost
like a there is existence of a future
person but experience good well it might
still be worthwhile for me to want such
a person to exist but not at the expense
of my existence but we can also imagine
some winding path where I have a lot of
experiences and training at llama
temples I'm getting Quantum Nano
machines injecting my brain slowly
learning how to use them to reach some
form of weird spirituality getting new
values and eventually ending up in the
same spot as that drastic change
You could argue this is a valid way of
developing values every step along the
time the very step along the way I
endorse I say yeah this seems to be a
good move sometimes I make a mistake and
I have to retreat to say yeah that was a
mistake oh yes let's forget the last
past decade I was so young and stupid
and gradually I find this because the
steps are gradual enough and I think
this goes back to many of our intuitions
about personality change if my
personality suddenly change because of
brain tumor that's not a valid change of
personality if I go to the same change
because I actually learned I didn't care
about certain things or had certain life
experiences it would be a valuable
change and it would be valid and
similarly a society that just one day
wakes up totally transformed has not
actually changed opinion it's just a new
Society but the society that realized
actually slavery seems to be bad and
some activists are saying yes we have
been telling you that for a long time
and here are even more compelling
arguments of an undergo transformation
into a society that says no to slavery
has done this along a very valid path we
can every step along the parts you can
endures and say this was because of this
conversation this was because of those
experiences so there's something about
gradual change as opposed to Quick
Change that makes it more legitimate
yeah gradual moral change would be more
legitimate than fast or you could say uh
radical moral change is that what you're
saying should be understood that is my
intuition another question is can you
actually make a good argument here for
why this is legitimate so the most
obvious thing is you can actually
backtrack if you make a mistake if
you're totally transformed there is in
some sense no way of backtracking
um although you might imagine of course
in that scenario that maybe there's an
undo button but usually when you are
like a certain being you rarely want to
undo that state but the really
interesting problem might be that the
the legitimacy is also because it's a
lot of local interactions a lot of
people organizations and ideas have a
legitimate interaction with each other
very normal interactions the brain tumor
changing somebody's personality even if
it's a nice personality change is in
some sense not the kind of thing that we
want to have as a tool for a change of
Personality although you might imagine
the future but maybe we have therapeutic
brain tumors to fix our personality
flaws but then they have become
legitimate because we're a tool and we
also have ways of thinking about do I
want to actually use this like a creepy
sounding treatment or do I want to
change my personality in a different way
so I think the legitimacy here has a lot
to do with both that the interactions
are of a kind we recognize as valid
and this is of course slightly tricky
because many of interactions with today
might regard as valid reasons to change
our mind might not always have been
regarded as valid so we use a lot of
Statistics these days to try to convince
people but this is the right course of
action the four statistics existed that
would have just been almost like
astrology indeed you could have argued
that today we don't regard astrological
arguments as valid reasons but once they
did what did that mean that they still
were valid because people felt they were
was it that the epistemic underpinnings
of astrology are so bad that they were
never good arguments even when people
believed them to be which I think is
what I would endorse
but there might be other forms of
interactions that also have these
interest aspects for example the idea of
a Marketplace of ideas that you find in
Liberal thinking is very much like good
ideas tend to win out against bad ideas
if we have his fair debate of course
without we have gotten in recent years
is maybe in the marketplace of idea on
social media the good ideas are not
going to win out which is a very
disturbing thought if you come from a
liberal tradition I think it's still not
entirely true but it's certainly clear
but it's not as simple as saying that
truth will always win out truth has a
lot of interesting marketing problems
marketing tends to help ideas win out
and it's neutral towards the truth of
the claimer
there's an interesting discussion about
how fast we should move towards what we
would consider
better future values so in in because
you could say one position is that if we
think that we've discovered something
that we in the future will value or will
find uh horrifics is to say that in the
future we predict that we will find a
factory farming horrific well then one
position is that we should we should
move towards eliminating factory farming
as quickly as possible and we could call
that uh the progressive position and
then on the other hand you could have
something you with that we could call
the conservative position which is that
there is some wisdom encoded in the way
we've been doing things and that we
should uh we should not overturn the
these traditions because they might have
some values that we don't fully
understand so we these two polls could
be how we think about navigating our way
to the to the better Futures we we want
to have
yeah I think that is a good uh scale and
you can of course imagine for example
the enlightened conservative position
which recognizes that yes and we also
have uh bias cognitive biases and
motivated thinking making me less
willing to change things that ought to
be changed so that would be a
conservative but do you recognize that
there might be a lot of hidden
information of a sister but also
recommend that I need to be skeptical
about it and you can find similarly the
progressive reality yeah we have a
post-track record of doing radical
changes with disastrous effects so you
can interpolate between them and even
try to find good methodologies for
either of these people to try to give
better Arguments for why this time
radical change would be a good idea or
this time we have a good reason to
believe there's a lot of wisdom embodied
in the practices of factory farming that
sounds like a really weird argument but
I'm not that conservative to having to
make that argument momentum do you find
it disorienting to think about values
from different perspectives meaning
values from from people held a thousand
years ago or values people will hold a
thousand years in the future do does
this make you does this make you worry
that uh there isn't anything real behind
all of this talk about value
I think there is definitely something
real going on and that is probably value
itself
we are kind of value
experience in value creating value
evaluating creatures and that goes back
a long time uh I in one part of a book I
think I might be mentioning what I
called vertebrate values I think we have
some value systems that go back at least
485 million years and those basic
systems kind of deep in our midbrains
are pretty Universal between us and
snakes and dinosaurs and the the
chickens those systems are there because
well we're organisms that need to select
between different actions and there are
various evolutionary patterns on what
actions are reliably good now then we
have added so much brain on top of that
that allows us to do both add entirely
new values when I enjoy mathematics it's
not just that my exploration
subsystem in my midbrain get to and be
active I seem to have generated entire
new subsystems and new forms of values
that can only be evaluated using a
human-like cerebral cortex
but these deep systems for Action
selection and somehow also giving us
experience they are very well preserved
and I think in the big scheme of things
of course that's a very peculiar
arrangement of atoms we don't find that
in Plants we don't find that in rocks or
Stars so there might be a lot of systems
that don't have any form of value or
evaluatives in the ability it might very
well be that we make artificial
intelligence with a very different kind
of system like that that might come into
being
but I do think that this vast variety of
things that you might evaluate the night
value or not value
it's useful to be aware that it's
different early on I mentioned that
our current Western culture is slightly
unique in that it's doubting itself
quite uh quite often indeed almost on an
industrial scale you can become a
best-selling offer by writing a book
about how we're wrong about important
things and really what to change this is
slightly unusual among most cultures
most cultures are rather complacent
about them being the best thing ever the
God shows them and embodying all the
best things and anybody disagreeing
better leave
uh I think this has been a great success
trick because actually having this
argument about that maybe we're the Bad
Guys
that allows us to try to become the good
guys whatever good actually means and I
think this is an important thing to have
at openness openness is really important
and this is where I think science
fiction has been tremendously helpful
for many of us because it allows you to
explore the idea about alien values
looking at Humanity from outside even
normal fiction in the literary sense is
important because it gives you other
perspectives and sometimes that gives
you a hint that your view of the world
is not necessarily the only one even if
you think you have an accurate view of
the world you might still recognize what
other people have different settings for
what is enjoyable or not yeah trying to
cash this out into practical action is
of course tricky but again being aware
that there is diversity and being
uncertain about what's right that is
very helpful against fanaticism
I think it's definitely a healthy
exercise both on a personal but also on
a civilizational level to think about
different perspectives and perhaps even
to think about really alien perspectives
and how we might be wrong about
fundamental things so one of the things
you you spend a lot of time on in your
book Grand Futures is thinking about the
limits of of what we can do within
physics is there perhaps something
analogous to we could call it the limits
of of morality so is there some boundary
conditions that we can think about and I
I've given this some thought and the
only thing that's that's uh
remotely plausible to me is something
like Consciousness is what delineates
what is within morality from what is
outside of morality so we don't there is
no uh plausible morality on which we
care about uh
say unconscious rocks um so do you think
of course philosophy and moral
philosophy is is miles away from from
the rigor of physics but do you think
that it makes sense to think about
boundary conditions for ethics
that there are probably a few one of the
more trivial ones but it's very
convenient is consistency you can just
look at the logical consists of
arguments say that yeah inconsistent
nonsense doesn't count as morality which
I think makes sense except that you will
always find at least some philosophers
argue no no inconsistent nonsense is uh
totally fine
um similarly Consciousness I think it's
pretty obvious that conscious entities
matter morally I'm not entirely certain
about whether non-conscious ethics don't
matter more there are certainly some
people who take ecocentric ethics to the
next step and say it's not just
ecosystem of a matter but even
non-living systems so there are some
people arguing against terraforming Mars
saying look there is shaped complexity
in those sand dunes so that means that
we shouldn't be turning that into a copy
of Earth or something new the problem is
of course if a rocket lands there and
Elon Musk steps out and starts building
a city to that's also shaped complexity
it's also an expression of the
creativity of the universe so it's not
entirely obvious that that argument
actually works so I think some of the
boundary conditions are like the that in
a ort implies cab there are limits to
our actions but very very wide
there is also a family limit or an upper
limit of value and that is simply that
we can't represent values Beyond a
certain point so I have a preprint with
David Mannheim about this
um so the basic thing is if I'm
evaluated with the room to do A and B
I'm trying to see which one has the
highest value to it but if I can't
distinguish the value of a and b then
basically I have to be neutral between
now you could say well wait a minute
value can go very far up right yeah but
that's basically a number you can
imagine me having a computer register in
my head and comparing these two numbers
and there is a limited number of bits I
have in my head to represent these
numbers
so the finiteness of my brain means that
there is an upper limit to the value I
can represent at this point you might
say wait a minute there are lexical
values too a human life is worth an
infinite amount of money more or less so
that always has priority but I can
represent that using bits too I just
need a slightly more in a creative
representation indeed you can say maybe
there were some superhuman values but at
one unit of that value is worth an
Infinity of human life so that's even
more important sure I can kind of keep
on adding to this hierarchy but in the
end it still needs bits to represent
things and bits are have to be
physically represented and finite
systems only have a finite amount of it
so that you get an upper limit to the
value you can evaluate and act on a
rational this limit is so ridiculous eye
but I don't think it matters in practice
it doesn't tell us anything about the
ultimate limits of what is actually
valuable in the universe but it does
show that there is a limit to our
ethical action if the universe did
contain kind of a real Infinities of
value we might not be able to
distinguish them from each other so our
actions are going to be neutral
but the really question is of course
well where does morality and ethics come
from how do you actually is very just an
infinite amount of self-consistent
systems here that could be true what is
it but actually the total number of
self-consistent systems are a small
number could be one or it could turn out
that was 17 self-consistent system so
billions of years hence emphasis are
just listing these 17 sisters and some
cool theorem in some alien language
explaining why these are the only ones
but then this post-uman students ask the
professor so which one should I believe
in and well that depends on your culture
or which one you choose we don't have a
good wave between that
so that is a one of the conclusions you
come to in in Grand Futures is this uh
finiteness of moral value in the
universe with this this is an
interesting way of mixing physics and
moral philosophy together and which is
and and as you just mentioned your point
here is just that uh well physics can
only support say uh brains or or
anything that could perform operations
uh that that brains do for a limited
amount of time so is that actually do do
you believe that the the universe is
finite in that sense and can it is it
potentially infinite in another sense
for example that something exists
forever but beings that matter ethically
do not
so so my basic model is that beings that
matter morally do exist in a finite
period of time along a timeline that has
so a finite starting point at the big
bank and then probably goes on
absolutely forever but we are in this
window where there is things to hope for
and fear for and care about and it is a
finite with it might be a very vast
window it might be 10 to the power of 36
years long it might be even longer than
that but there is only a finite amount
of stuff that we starting from Earth can
put our the hands on and turn into mind
the Consciousness or whatever it is
so I think we're living in a vast but
finite universe and this is interesting
because some people get very depressed
when they hear about even though I'm
using scientific notation to show these
absurdly big numbers that don't even
make sense in any human context which
are for all practical purposes infinite
compared to normal human wants but other
people say no I want true infinitive and
it's not entirely clear what true
infinitive would give us
um it's a bit like Donald knife in one
of his essays he defines a number
related to Graham's number which is just
unbelievably huge and then he points out
that well if God gave me a lifespan
equivalent to this number that's about
as good as eternal life because well it
is so much longer than anything that
would you can actually possibly imagine
and indeed if you think about theology
anything religious people ever wanted
God to be can also be expressed as a
kind of okay if God is finitely powerful
but that number powerful that's still
good enough for all the religions that
ever existed
so quite often we have this hard time
imagining just how huge finite things
can be
we quite often think that true Infinity
must be a really important thing but
actually the finite stuff is quite
valuable most of the stuff that really
matters to us in our normal lives are
finite things their finite loves very
finite the lifespans find out the
insights yet they make our lives so good
and even adding a bit to that might make
them exponentially better
but still finite the problem is we quite
often fall in love with this abstraction
of infinitive yet the finite World we're
surrounded with in its complicated
structure I think we get a lot of value
but might even disappear when you're out
in the true land of Infinities where
everything kind of has a nice limiting
point
how would value disappear if the
universe turned out to be infinite in
what sense would would value disappear
I'm not certain it would disappear
rather you would end up with situation
maybe there is something that has
infinite value and well what about
something else that also has infant
value if they are the same infinitive in
that case uh very equally valid Etc
in that case you could also say we both
forgot value
of 10 units you can rescale things the
real problem is rather
when you move around in a discrete set
of numbers like the integers uh that
discreetness creates a lot of structure
we have a primes we have a lot of
properties of evenness and oddness that
creates a complex tapestry when you move
over to the a slightly richer
representation like rational numbers you
get many more numbers in some sense at
this point of course a set theoretician
will be wagging his fingers saying no no
the cardinality of those two sets are
the same you get a lot more freedom
though once you move over to the real
numbers you get even more freedom and a
lot of very weird and wacky numbers that
we normally don't use but many of the
problems disappear or rather the
uniqueness of particular numbers just
melt away into the Continuum and I think
the same thing happens when you move
over to having real Infinities around
yeah many finite things are just all the
same
now this is perhaps me not understanding
Infinity because I have a wrong
mathematical intuition and a woefully
finite brain but it seems to me that
actually making a lot out of finite
stuff is going to keep us busy in for a
long time and it might very well turn
out that had we infinite time we would
still be kind of dealing with the finite
stuff indefinitely far
because there are many weird things
about finite objects one of my favorite
facts is that if you think about the
kolmogorov complexity of something that
is the shortest computer program that
can generate the bit string that
describes it for most numbers since most
numbers are random sequencer ones and
zeros that that complexity is about
equal to the numbers as you move to
bigger and bigger number the complexity
just grows indefinitely personal numbers
that have low complexity but you can
just write them with all ones or one
full over ten thousand zeros and that's
a short program but the program that
generates all of the numbers that's a
very simple computer program so the
complexity of all numbers together is
very small yet there are many numbers
inside that set that are much more
complex but the way of finding them is
of course counting up the numbers and
dealing with the finite finite numbers
from themselves rather than dealing with
the whole system
there is perhaps a worry that moral
philosophy has gotten ahead of itself
here if we return to this to this uh
metaphor of humanity as an immature
teenager maybe maybe us as a teenager
now we've gotten very fascinated with
the limits of what we can do and uh
there is also or perhaps we should focus
more on a more common sense uh view of
what we should do say uh so we've been
discussing how we could alienate
ourselves from our own values uh
thinking about future values and past
values we've been thinking about whether
an enormous but finite a future would be
worse than an infinite future and so on
but if we're thinking about uh whether
it would be good for Humanity to destroy
itself well there's a pretty Common
Sense answer there if if we and it's a
it's an answer that we that we use uh
every day in our own lives which is just
we we look both ways when we cross the
street uh we spend a lot of lots of our
resources just trying to prevent just
the people alive today from from dying
of disease and War and so on and so I
think it's important to stress that
nothing about preventing the extinction
of humanity by engineer pandemics or a
nuclear war or Advanced artificial
intelligence depends on these esoteric
philosophical discussions about out
value even though they are extremely
interesting to me at least yeah and I
think it's also useful to hedge one's
bets I think understanding a bit about
why the landscape helps you appreciate
the practicalities of okay how do we
make sure that the governance of
bioweapons is sensible
I think in particular one of the
importances of this weirder parts of
Ethics is helping us think about
priority setting because we still need
to think about okay I need to select a
carrier am I going to diplomacy to try
to reduce nuclear weapons risk or am I
going to technology to try to fix better
energy sources so we survive or should I
be trying to make a safe AI well maybe I
should actually go and go and work on
the maloria pednet that priority setting
to some extent depends on the weird
questions there are for example those
critiques of effective altruism arguing
that look if you think that the end of
the world is infinitely bad then you
need to put in all effort for that and
that is crazy which is basically in the
same formal form as critique in Peter
singer's view that we should be putting
all our effort into helping the poor in
the world so during the abstraction
reality hey these arguments have some
interesting similarities and
dissimilarities what kind of learn is
helping you buttress your priorities
so generally my approach to many of
these things is I think it's worthwhile
to have some people work on the really
far out stuff I think it's also not
worth having too many people here I'm
pretty happy to be relatively alone in
writing books uh about what to do in the
next quadrillion years I have a feeling
that we're not going to need updating
that too much I have some ideas for how
to build a Solar Shield to help Earth in
a billion years but it's not exactly
urgent to finalize those things we're
going to have much better technology in
just a million years
but having a sense of where you are in
the big scheme of things even if that's
somewhat templative I think is very
helpful for example the discussion about
changing values in the far future some
of that of course affects us when we
think about how our values are changing
as a culture right now over the next few
years new social medias are going to
change how culture works they're going
to favor some values and disfavor others
we might want to think about how much
importance we should put on that and
make sure because some conservatives are
saying look these medias are really bad
they're threatening really important
values and that's why we need to ban
them While others would say wait I mean
a change of values is actually fairly
okay
and that debate is useful to have so I
think it's a bit like the big history
idea in order to understand history it's
a good idea to actually understand
archeology and paleontology and the
history of life on earth and the geology
of Earth and the astrophysics of what
where Earth came from you can zoom in
and zoom out quite often when you try to
understand history you will have to look
at what was happening in that country at
the time but occasionally it's useful to
know that country is what it is because
it's a mountainous place and those
mountains came about because of that
folding of Earth's plates and sometimes
that also allows you to zoom in and zoom
in the flexible way for the future the
long noun Foundation have been arguing
that we should think of it now as 10 000
years which is kind of a nice convenient
length of time but I think we actually
need to be able to zoom out and zoom in
much more so we can zoom out and see the
potential grandness of future the
strangeness of the future and then we
can zoom back in and think about what am
I doing next Tuesday in the light of
this one of the uses of his ore in front
of exhaust is to realize that a lot of
stuff we're doing is petting it's super
useful to recognize that actually I
don't need to sweat those details I
should be working on something that
really matters
that is one of the benefits but I do
take to your point but yep the far out
reaches a metaphics and the metaphysics
most of them don't matter for whether to
give away your money to the Baker on the
street for that you might need to think
more about the politics or your own
psychology
fantastic okay Anders do you want to do
a lightning round with with uh quick
answers to to spices I'm excited to do
quick answers there's a risk that I'm
feeling that but yeah let's try let's
try okay and this will be unrelated to
each other will we have will we have
uploaded Minds before we have artificial
general intelligence
uh I don't know uh I think the I can
give a time estimate roughly for
uploaded Minds if they are possible but
I have no clue about AGI
you can give it your time instrument so
I would give 50 chance that we got them
by 2060. uh maybe if we push it we might
be getting uploaded mines by 2040 if
we're really lucky but AGI it could
happen in 10 years it could take a
hundred years
so you're what we could call AI
timelines are still very very open even
though you've spent decades thinking
about this uh or perhaps because you've
spent decades thinking about this that
that's an interesting fact
yeah uh generally my my experience of AR
Timeless is we don't know how to predict
them
and that is itself useful it gives us a
sense that okay we need to act urgently
because it can happen soon but we should
also expect that it's going to take much
longer than they expected
will Humanity ever leave the solar
system
I think Humanity in defined as some
something mentally dissembled from
humans will leave the solar system with
a fairly high probability will a
biological human ever leave a solar
system I think if that happens it's
going to be some kind of weird Stunt by
an advanced civilizer showing that look
we can even send a person over to Alpha
Contour of course people have been
living there for thousands of years but
we can afford to even send a person here
because it would be so difficult to
transport a biological human through
space or
Interstellar travel in that sense and so
they might even parade it around as an
example of how advanced they are
scientifically that's interesting
showing off now there is another way in
biological humans might leave a solar
system so that's the slow boat approach
so imagine that you have self-sufficient
habitats that can mine deuterium to run
Fusion reactors from cometary eyes and
get enough carbon and other compounds
from bad guys to build new habitats and
biospheres you could imagine these guys
settling the Oort cloud and over time
they might migrate into the workload or
overlapping solar system and spread by
diffusion between Stars passing by each
other this way over a span of about four
billion years we could actually settle
the whole galaxy and at that point
usually in my simulations the ethereum
runs out that they have to settle in
their solar systems uh that they're not
used to
how worried should we be about a future
totalitarian world government
I think we should be fairly worried
about that we're seeing more and more
tools for automated totalitarianism
they're still clunky but then again uh
so where the surveillance cameras uh
back in the 1940s uh many uh
authoritarian governments really love
the ability of using Ai and automation
to keep their population alive so I
think we need to make safeguards here we
need to invent a better science of
making safe and sane governance
are there aliens in the universe
I think the universe is spatially
infinite so I think the probability is
essentially one but I think it's
sparsely populated I think our nearest
neighbors are probably a billion light
years away or something like that so I'm
hoping we will get to meet them but it's
going to be far in the future
what are some of the most interesting
unanswered questions about Grand futures
or perhaps thinking in the tradition of
big history or Institute disciplinary
science as as you've done with your book
what is what would you be really
delighted to to hear a new paper coming
out about
one is what is the structure of History
it seems like there are some important
hinge points where things could go in
different directions
and we can certainly cite various
historical events that look like that
but were they actually hinge points
maybe a lot of histories May much more
stable or a lot of history is actually
totally chaotic and random so na
minuscule change just makes everything
go in a different direction I would love
to have a general theory about how the
distribution of importance of points in
time and space distribute to themselves
another question I'm interested in is is
there really interesting cryophysics we
know a fair bit about physics at high
temperatures and chemistry at our normal
temperature there are some reactions
that you can do in a lab in liquid
nitrogen that cannot happen normally at
higher temperatures because the
compounds are so unstable what about
chemistry and physics close to absolute
zero we know weird things like
superfluidity and superconductivity
happen over other complex things like
that that happen close to absolute zero
that we totally overlooked because we're
such hot creatures
do you think we are currently at a hinge
in history meaning that this is a
particularly important time and our
actions matter particularly
much today
I think we're likely at the hinge I it
might not be the hinge the most
important moment in the history but it
certainly seems like there is a lot of
important turbulence and Choice points
here we might be setting standards that
are going to affect how we set up space
biotechnology nanotechnology and
artificial intelligence we are making
choices about what to invest in and
we're also somewhat disjointed in our
governance I think this might be a
rather crucial period
for listeners who find this conversation
insightful what book should they read
now of course aside from Grand from
Brand Futures which everyone should
write Futures is taking its time I'm
hopefully done with it before the
singularity or something but
one book that really inspired me was
barrel and tippler's the anthropic
cosmological principle my book is in
some sense a sequel so in that book they
looked at Humanity's place in the
universe and combined a lot of
philosophy with looking at physics and
their future possibility it's a bit
dated but still an amazing Masterpiece
I'm also very fond of Freeman Dyson's
work because that combines a deep
Humanity as well as a very inquiring
mind poking at interesting questions
from father angles so disturbing the
universe might be a great starting point
and then we have all of stapled on
science fiction novels lost the first
man and star maker these ones are really
old science fiction stories but
especially star maker is the great grand
future story it's about intelligence in
the universe so it's groping towards
survival and complexity and trying to
figure out what is it all about it's
unimaginably vast and it's very
different from everything before and
after
should the average person sign up for
cryogenics or cryonics
so I did a cost benefit calculation
where I estimated what is the value of
my life to me basically how much in
depth would I be willing to go uh the
the before I said nah that's not fun
enough and then I did an estimate of the
cost of a cryonics and concluded I think
it's more likely uh than that threshold
it's actually rational for me to given
how much I value my life that I should
be paying for cryops but other people
might make a different estimate so the
average person should try to do their
own estimation
fantastic Anders uh thank you for coming
on the podcast thank you this has been
so much fun